avec l'arrivée des beaux jours il faut
penser à venir sécuriser sa maison pour
éviter les cambriolages alors on sait
bien évidemment que lorsqu'on va partir
en vacances on peut partir en weekend
enfin bref ça peut arriver à peu près
tout le temps mais il y a une vraie
recrudescence au moment de l'été pensez
à venir sécuriser votre maison avec des
solutions de sécurité justement
aujourd'hui c'est une vidéo qui
réalisait en partenariat avec netatmo
parce que netatmo m'a dit gros est-ce
que tu veux présenter notre solution de
sécurité pour la maison et j'ai dit bien
évidemment oui pourquoi pour plusieurs
raisons déjà l'état de mots c'est une
boîte française qui existe depuis 2011
ça fait partie du groupe Legrand c'est
une boîte sérieuse qui propose des
produits de qualité et ont plus de ça je
suis allé visiter chez eux il y a
quelques jours pour montrer comment
est-ce qu'ils font tout ça juste à côté
de Paris à Boulogne-Billancourt c'est
vachement intéressant tout est fait
maison de la conception la réflexion il
y a les ingénieurs et ça c'est vraiment
cool donc il y a juste la fabrication
qui est externalisée tout le reste est
conçu directement chez netatmo à côté de
Paris donc je trouve ça déjà extrêmement
rassurant en plus de ça ils ont un autre
point qui est extrêmement fort et ça
c'est vachement cool à savoir que vous
n'avez aucun abonnement aucun coût
additionnel aucun frais caché vous
achetez vos produits de chez netatmo et
ils vont fonctionner tout seul alors
vous avez une application vous allez
voir c'est vachement mais il n'y a pas
besoin de prendre un abonnement
quelconque vous avez soit tout stocké
directement dans le produit et je vous
explique dans quelques instants soit
stocké dans le Cloud à vous de voir on
peut venir le paramétrer et ça c'est
vachement bien on a donc des produits
intelligents qui vont servir à maximiser
votre expérience à la maison en termes
de sécurité il y a pas mal de choses une
fois de plus aller jeter un coup d'œil
directement sur le site de netatmo je
vous mets un lien en bas dans la
description 100% sécurisé vos données et
votre vie privée sont complètement
respectées 100% évolutif également avec
des mises à jour des nouvelles
fonctionnalités qui sont ajoutées
régulièrement et gratuitement c'est
pratique c'est bien c'est cool ça me
plaît donc ça c'est chouette on y va on
va aujourd'hui se parler de sécurisation
de votre maison grâce à des produits
made in France ça c'est chouette allez
on y va
on va
commencer alors j'ai pas pas mal de
produits à venir vous présenter pour la
sécurisation on va d'abord commencer par
une caméra extérieure parce que tout
commence à l'extérieur de notre maison
bien évidemment s'il y a un intrus va
arriver chez vous il va commencer par
passer par l'extérieur à moins qu'il est
le don de téléportation auquel cas il
est extrêmement fort donc ça commence
par la caméra extérieure qui s'appelle
ici comme vous le voyez c'est la Smart à
outre caméra mais c'est la caméra pour
l'extérieur la caméra intelligente avec
sirène qu'est-ce qui se passe quelqu'un
arrive dans votre maison par l'extérieur
et bien votre caméra va venir le repérer
que ce soit à quelqu'un que soit
d'ailleurs un véhicule venir vous en
alerter et vous avez la capacité vous
directement depuis votre application
quand vous êtes alerté d'appuyer sur le
bouton déclencher l'alarme et là ça va
couiller du feu de dieu 105 décibels
d'alarme croyez moi que ça gueule
vraiment vraiment fort donc ça c'est
très très bien ce produit s'installe
très facilement à l'extérieur soit en
remplacement d'un produit qui était déjà
là une lampe on peut imaginer vous le
liée au wifi très très facilement la
configuration se fait ensuite via
l'application et c'est parti mon Tintin
vous êtes tranquille moi j'ai ma caméra
extérieure qui est positionnée juste là
qui est fixé sur mon mur alors j'ai le
câblage qui court à côté vous êtes donc
alerté en temps réel s'il y a une
intrusion tout le stockage des vidéos ça
fait directement dans une carte micro SD
qui est à l'intérieur totalement chiffré
donc personne ne pourra y avoir accès et
si vous le souhaitez vous en plus de ça
venir le stocker dans le Cloud facile et
l'autre truc qui est cool c'est que vous
avez un grand éclairage LED sur le
dessus et vous voyez vous avez votre
caméra qui est en fait ici et au dessus
c'est la lumière LED ça éclairage aura
plusieurs fonctions leur bien évidemment
ça servira la nuit lorsqu'on intrus
arrivera et bien lui mettre le flash
dans la gueule c'est assez dissuasif et
puis vous lorsque vous rentrez chez vous
vous ferez vous une lumière pour vous
indiquer le chemin et éviter de taper
contre un arbre un poteau ou je ne sais
quoi encore et bien évidemment vous avez
une vision infrarouge pour la nuit ce
qui est pratique c'est que comme elle
est effectivement positionnée en haut et
bien elle va venir à capter dans un sens
et dans l'autre elle sera exactement ce
qui se passe chez moi et puis je vous
dis une fois de plus qui est vachement
bien ici c'est que vous avez toute cette
lumière LED qui va venir à m'éclairer la
nuit lorsque j'en ai besoin cette caméra
pour l'extérieur est compatible homme
kit mais également avec l'assistant
Google comme la caméra intérieure et je
vais vous expliquer dans quelques
instants comment ça fonctionne et notre
truc est super important elle est
protégée contre les UV et les
intempéries grâce à la norme HzO
l'application est aussi super cool et
très intuitive vous allez venir naviguer
à travers vos différents objets donc là
je suis dans le à la maison j'ai
également mes accessoires qui sont là
qui sont connectés on peut avoir si on
souhaite une sonnette vidéo intelligente
mais je l'ai pas mais vous pouvez venir
la voir et vous l'auriez ici le
détecteur de fumée également et après je
vais avoir ailleurs tout le monde est
bien à la maison tout va bien donc là je
vois qu'il y a ma tronche en fait ça va
me montrer ce qui s'est passé
directement dans ma timeline donc là je
vois qu'il y a 15 heures 11 et bien
j'étais en train de marcher ça c'est la
caméra extérieure donc là voyez je suis
en train de marcher derrière ça m'a bien
reconnu Aurélien a été vu alors je vois
quel moment l'alarme a commencé à sonner
je vois à quel moment l'alarme a été
coupée et puis j'ai toutes les infos
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé là j'ai une
petite patte de chien ça veut dire qu'il
y a mon chien qui a été détecté des
humains également donc là il y a pas de
véhicule sinon ça m'aurait indiqué
effectivement s'il y avait eu un
véhicule vu que c'est la caméra et
extérieure ça m'indique à quelle heure à
quelle heure à quelle heure et je vois
tout effectivement j'ai claqué dessus et
j'aurais ensuite la vidéo qui correspond
donc tout ça vachement bien et super
sécurisant je vois également que j'ai
une mise à jour qui a été poussée à
11h41 sur ma caméra intérieure une fois
que vous avez protégé l'extérieur de
votre maison et bien il faut passer à
l'intérieur alors tout commence à
l'intérieur avec la caméra pour
l'intérieur la caméra intérieure
intelligente de netatmo alors en plus
d'être plutôt jolie et très mignonne qui
se fondera parfaitement dans votre
intérieur elle va venir totalement
sécurisé votre intérieur c'est le point
central en gros de la sécurisation
intérieure avec netatmo à savoir qu'elle
s'installe extrêmement facilement la
caméra je l'ai positionné ici comme ça
elle a une vue d'ensemble ce qui lui
permet de voir exactement tout ce qui se
passe dans la maison en plus que je
trouve très bien c'est qu'elle est
vachement jolie donc vous voyez elle
passe très très bien devant mes vieux
DVD comme ça comme ça vous voyez en même
temps ce que je regarde et puis mes
vieux jeux vidéo derrière vous la
connecter soit en wi-fi soit en filaire
grâce à une prise RJ45 que vous avez
derrière si quelqu'un rentre chez vous
qui bien évidemment n'est pas vous
soyons clair là-dessus vous allez
recevoir directement une notification
qui vous alertera quelqu'un qui est là
vous pouvez prévenir les forces de
l'ordre très facilement parce que il y a
de la reconnaissance faciale et ces
trucs qui est vraiment vraiment
intéressant qui va en plus de ça sur le
respect de la vie privée à savoir que la
caméra la reconnaissance faciale elle
vous reconnaît et dès que c'est vous
bien évidemment elle va pas enregistrer
elle sait que vous êtes là vous êtes
tranquille vous êtes peinard et ça c'est
bien ça fonctionne également avec les
membres de votre famille avec vos
proches donc si vous avez un proche qui
vient vous visiter ou si vous avez
quelqu'un dans votre maison un membre de
votre famille vous vivez à plusieurs et
bien les visages sont reconnus ou
quelqu'un s'annoncera aucune
notification et aucun enregistrement
alors moi j'ai fait le choix de la
connecter en RJ45 mais vous pouvez la
connecter en wifi sans aucun problème ça
c'est à vous de voir et ça dépend de la
configuration intérieure de chacun et
l'autre point qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est que il y a un truc qui
est très intelligent la caméra cela sera
lorsque vous êtes là donc lorsque vous
partez et bien il va lancer la sécurité
et lorsque vous arrivez elle l'enlève
comme ça vous êtes peinard pas besoin
d'y penser par vous-même vous êtes
tranquille et c'est tout le temps
sécurisé chez vous de la même manière
que sur la caméra extérieure est bien
tout ce qui va être mise à jour toutes
les nouveautés tout ça a lieu sans
abonnement et son cou supplémentaire
vous avez également une vision
infrarouge pour la nuit et vos données
sont stockées soit sur une carte micro
SD que vous avez à l'intérieur soit dans
le Cloud et bien évidemment compatible
également avec Siri et Google assistant
donc là je vois exactement tout ce qui
se passe à l'intérieur et à l'extérieur
donc là vous voyez je suis sur la caméra
extérieure ça me marque en haut et puis
hop là je peux switcher sur l'autre et
voir en direct ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur donc même si je suis loin de
chez moi je peux en permanence savoir ce
qui se passe chez moi une fois que vous
avez installé votre caméra une fois que
la base de la sécurité à l'intérieur de
votre maison est configuré et bien on
peut venir mettre le deuxième accessoire
le deuxième accessoire c'est quoi et
bien c'est la sirène intérieure sirène
qui ira couiner jusqu'à
110 décibels autant dire que si ça fera
fuir et cambrioleur sans 10 décibels
c'est extrêmement fort extrêmement fort
même principe que la caméra intérieure
elle fait partie le système de sécurité
alors que lorsque vous partez de chez
vous et bien elle s'active et lorsque
vous revenez chez vous et bien elle se
désactive comme ça vous n'avez pas vous
dire tiens ce que j'ai bien pensé à
désactiver le système de surveillance ça
va ça ne criera pas vous n'aurez pas les
110 estimés dans les oreilles ça
croyez-moi c'est quand même plutôt pas
mal pas loin de ma caméra j'ai mis ma
sirène ma sirène elle est juste ici et
ma sirène je l'ai mise en hauteur
pourquoi et bien parce que je veux pas
qu'on puisse l'attraper facilement que
ce soit une vraie contrainte en plus de
ça le son va diffuser un peu partout ça
c'est quand même vachement bien et puis
lorsque vous avez des intrus qui arrive
chez vous j'ai pas envie qu'ils aient
accès à la sirène très très facilement
je veux que ça gueule je veux que ça les
éloigne et je veux les faire fuir le
plus rapidement possible et il y a un
autre truc qui est vachement bien c'est
qu'il y a une simulation de présence
ouais elle va pouvoir venir diffuser des
sons qui sont préenregistrés pour faire
croire que vous êtes là directement chez
vous lorsque vous êtes absent aboiement
pour faire croire qu'il y a un chien qui
est là bébé qui pleure également des
bruits domestiques c'est plutôt le bruit
d'un espèce d'aspirateur j'ai des petits
billets et si vous le souhaitez vous
pouvez venir la déclencher très
facilement en un clic dans l'application
je dirais que le troisième accessoire et
non des mois pour la sécurisation de
votre intérieur c'est ça et bien ça va
être le détecteur d'ouverture de porte
enfin le détecteur d'ouverture de porte
et de fenêtres et puis il y a pas loin
de ma caméra et pas loin de ma sirène
j'ai mis mon détecteur ici sur ma porte
fenêtre alors détecteur d'ouverture et
de fermeture qui va pouvoir savoir si on
est en train d'ouvrir ma porte ou si on
est en train de la fermer donc j'en ai
positionné une ici sur cette porte
fenêtre mais également à différence
endroit stratégiques que bien évidemment
je vais vous montrerai pas pour des
questions de sécurité c'est vraiment le
deuxième accessoire ici qui est le plus
important après la sirène en fait ce qui
va se passer c'est que ça permet de
détecter les intrusions avant même
qu'elle ne surviennent des quelqu'un et
arriver sur votre propriété et si cette
personne n'a pas été captée par la
caméra extérieure et bien lorsqu'elle va
vouloir faire bouger une fenêtre ou une
porte taper dedans comment ça vouloir
casser commencer à taper et bien les
détecteurs vont le capter vous serez
donc alerté par notification directement
sur votre smartphone et ensuite ça va
être la sirène qui prendra le relais et
qui fera son job pour faire fuir les
assaillants ça détecte donc les
vibrations sur vos portes et sur vos
fenêtres il y a un autre petit point qui
est aussi intéressant du fait de les
avoir au-delà du côté sécurisation ça
vous permet de savoir lorsque vous êtes
absent est-ce que vos portes et est-ce
que vos fenêtres sont bien fermées vous
voyez typiquement que les détecteurs que
j'ai installés ici j'en ai deux qui sont
installés et bien m'indique que les
portes sont fermées GK hop tourner et
paf et là elle est passée à ouverte et
ensuite la refermer et elle repasse à
fermer et ça c'est vachement pratique
l'installation est également très facile
vous le paramétrez très rapidement ce
sont des monoblocs que vous venez
installer directement sur vos portes et
vos fenêtres ils sont étanches il colle
facilement ils ont des piles à
l'intérieur c'est pratique c'est simple
bref ça marche très bien et après je
vais cliquer sur les trois petits points
en haut à droite et je viens tout
paramétrer donc là j'ai le son qui est
éteint alors ce qui est assez marrant
c'est que je peux appuyer dessus donc là
je clique sur alarme forte ça va sonner
chez moi au niveau de mes alarmes
intérieur et extérieur le déclenchement
automatique prévenir la caméra que tout
le monde est parti donc là je peux lui
dire et là c'est le niveau d'alerte
maximale et puis ensuite je l'ai élément
par élément l'élément du haut et bien
c'est ma caméra intérieure donc là elle
est surveillance est activée je diffuse
également sur homekit là hop là je peux
dans les paramètres le témoin de
streaming qui va venir clignoter en
rouge si quelqu'un regarde la vidéo à
distance la vision nocturne infrarouge
qui est automatique enregistrée avec un
effet miroir le micro qui est activé et
un code de sécurité demandé à chaque
fois que je suspends la surveillance et
puis après j'ai tout mes réglages sur ma
caméra extérieure activer désactiver la
surveillance rotation de l'image
également le micro le code de sécurité
comme sur la caméra diffuser directement
au niveau de home
cru des sens des cambriolages à la
période de l'été donc ça serait quand
même relativement dommage de ne pas être
venu vous sécuriser une fois que c'est
fait vous êtes peinard et une fois de
plus tout ça sans coup sans surcoût sans
abonnement sans rien et pour moi ça
c'est quand même vachement bien donc
dites moi ce que vous en pensez est-ce
que vous avez déjà acheté des produits
de netatmo en sachant que chez netatmo
là je vous présente ses produits mais il
y en a plein d'autres vous avez des
produits pour la qualité de l'air vous
avez plein de produits il y a des têtes
thermostatique vraiment une solution
complète pour la maison connectée et si
comme moi vous aimez connecter votre
maison et bien vous avez de quoi faire
une fois de plus dites-moi ce que vous
en pensez en bas dans les commentaires
et puis surtout merci à netatmo d'avoir
sponsorisé cette vidéo voilà je vous
embrasse à très bientôt pour la soin de
VOUS Ciao